you probably recognize these ice-cream
pellets as the ice cream of the future
they're dippin dots a summertime staple
but this confectionery treat didn't
start as well ice cream
it started as cow feed dippin dots were
invented in the 80s not by an ice cream
brand but by a microbiologist Curtis
Jones
specialized in cryogenics in 1987 he was
working for a biotech company in
Kentucky trying to figure out how to
make food for farm animals more
efficient his big breakthrough came when
he flash froze cattle feed 350 degrees
below zero
which produce small pellets
serendipitously Curtis loved making ice
cream next thing he knew he was using
liquid nitrogen to freeze ice cream at
extremely low temperatures and ended up
with small beads of it when eaten the
natural heat of the mouth melted the
beads and thus dippin dots was born a
year later he formed the company out of
his parents garage in Illinois but there
was a problem Curtis had nowhere to sell
the product dippin dots need to be
stored at such a cold temperature that
it made it impossible for grocery stores
to house the tasty treat so he got
creative and marketed his product to
alternate locations now they're sold at
amusement parks festivals zoos and other
summertime destinations but whether or
not they really are the ice cream of the
future we'll just have to wait and see